hey guys Ryan right here so a lot of
people have been telling me to check out
a sci-fi action comedy trailer for a hit
for something called lazer team don't
know what it is but I I saw like there
was an article about it on Collider but
I didn't check it out because I don't
like to read roosterteeth
in 1977 the signal was received it is
the only green incidental alien contact
this source of the transmission has
never been revealed
how they are not [ __ ] flames you
expecting us to catch on fire
is gonna be here in two days are you
with me I'm having a quarter mile at a
time
if anything comes you I will block it
anyway because I never leave you but the
rest of us don't write here the team
part stupid name
interesting I'm probably gonna
disappoint a lot of people here
not sure why everyone was telling me
that I should really check out this
trailer I mean the movie looks ok I mean
yeah sure we've seen the plot before
aliens are coming underdogs are the ones
who are gonna save us you know there's
like attack the block there's the watch
I don't know how many jokes of someone
firing a laser and then flying back I
can handle it might be funny I'm not
sure some of the comedy feels a little
bit forced like I know it's supposed to
be like offbeat humor but a lot of it
feels like the editing might be a little
weird I don't know it's probably just
the way the trailer is cut one thing I'm
interested in seeing is there's a lot of
physical comedy and physical comedy very
difficult to actually make it funny we
get a lot more dialogue driven comedies
now this seems like there's a lot of
like painful humor in there that's also
one of the reasons what I like to watch
it because even when slapstick is bad
it's still entertaining to me not saying
it's going to be bad I'm saying that
like even if it happens to be bad I will
probably still enjoy that and the other
thing too it could be really badass you
know like there's glimpses of action
sequences in here they look like they're
shot pretty cool for the most part so
while it doesn't look like the funniest
thing on the planet to me it looks like
it'll be fast paced of the entertaining
enough and if there's some cool action
that it will probably make it even a lot
better I like sci-fi comedies that have
a little bit of horror in it and I feel
like this film could have some of that
like that's why I really like attack the
block because there's like actual fear
injected in it but at the same time it's
a hilarious film not saying this has to
be attacked the block I'm just saying
like I like that injection of genre into
a sci-fi action comedy like this tale
like Mars Attacks like that was kind of
scary you know but it was really funny
anyway guys yeah thanks for letting me
know that was out if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects and you can follow me on
Facebook Instagram Twitter where I
Instagram photos of my dick and then
I upload it to Twitter and Facebook and
on Facebook it usually gets shared a lot
and it gets retweeted often it's the
only thing I do on my social networks is
pictures of my dick mark Ritchie hey
guys so I was filming a spider-man short
film at school and I got a boner after
kissing the girl who played Gwen it was
really embarrassing so I posted on
YouTube for the world to see can I get a
shout out my channel was making a movie
man mark we're watching your [ __ ]
hard haha
there are skits I've done on this
channel where people are like wait is
this real
I'm wondering that too who like is yours
real I've done a lot of [ __ ] on here
you know I've like shown my ass a few
times I don't mind getting naked but
never has someone seen my erection
through my pants because I feel like I
would let down a lot of people it's not
as big as I hoped it would be I thought
by now it would have grown I water it
like every day by did you really
inspired me
you're more bold than I am yeah I'm
gonna try to get an erection on camera
because watching you was pretty hard oh
well what did you